and I don't think you're going to want
to miss it here now with a preview of
the big event chairman of the Harris
pole Mark Penn and former Arkansas
Governor Mike Huckabee is with us all
right Mark Penn let's just examine from
a political point of view you're a
pollster you work with the clintons for
years um from a political point of view
do you think I I would argue that both
are putting themselves in the arena
they're both putting themselves in the
Octagon here um I think they're both
willing to take a risk to do it and I
think it's healthy for the country
that's my take your
take yeah definitely look I I think this
is a highrisk event for everybody
involved I think Ronda santis expected
to be much higher in the presidential
race against Donald Trump so this has
now turned into something that might
have been risky where he has everything
to lose where maybe if he pulls off a
great debate here and defends his record
he'll actually come up a few points in
the presidential race Nome he doesn't
have much to to lose here he's not
expecting to get Fox voters to vote for
him no matter what on the other hand if
he can slay Ronda santis that's going to
put him in a great position in the
presidential Bullpen which is really
what he's interested in getting you know
we talk on awful lot Governor Huckabee
about Joe Biden being weak and frail in
a cognitive mess um it has to be viewed
as a reality that maybe come November of
next year that Joe Biden is not going to
be on the ticket as presidential
candidate for the Democrats do you agree
with
that yeah I do and I think Mark had a
great point this is a terrific
opportunity for Gavin Nome it is risky
for the santis but I also want to say
kudos to Gavin Nome uh this is a bold
move on his part to come to the Sha
Hannity Show I mean heck a lot of us who
are Republicans are afraid to come on
your show and here's Gavin Newsome
showing up so I think it's to his credit
well it is to his credit that he's
willing to do it because a lot of people
simply would say no I don't think I'm
going to be treated fairly I think you
will treat him fairly for DeSantis he
needs the Boost he needs to be able to
show that he can get on this kind of
stage because he hasn't been on a stage
yet in the debates in which he just
walked away with it so uh his numbers
have not moved they've uh if anything
declined since he first got in he needs
a boo
and especially with Nikki Haley now
getting the nod from a lot of the mega
donors which frankly may be more helpful
to Ronda santis uh than hurtful I think
it's a great opportunity for both of
them you know Governor tell me if you
think my thinking is right on this
because going into this as I've been
preparing for this debate and reading
volumes and volumes of material
background positions Etc looking at
their records you know what what really
fundamentally I don't think a lot of the
questions will be that big a surprise
cuz my mindset is on the fact that
states can have an even bigger impact on
people's everyday lives and their
policies can have an impact on people's
everyday lives than anything else and
you're looking at two
diametrically uh two two opposite
political points of view here two
different governing philosophies I don't
think they could be any more different
and they also seem to I don't know if
it's real or not but they don't really
seem to like each other very much um but
I really want to know you know which
policies work best for people you were
once a governor what would you like to
hear in this
debate well I think they both need to
explain their philosophy of government
what is the role of government they come
at it from a very different point of
view uh our Founders had this brilliant
idea called federalism in which the
states would be the Laboratories of
democracy we would find out what works
and what doesn't we wouldn't make a
national mistake and subject all the
states Now 50 of them uh to a disaster
and a Washington centered government is
a disaster a state centered government
is really workable and quite frankly
desirable we can learn from Democrats
those of us who are Republican and
Democrats can learn from uh the
Republicans if there's an idea that
actually is pragmatic and works and
that's how it's been working in the
states I think that's a great
opportunity for these two Governors to
sell their ideas to sell their point of
view and their philosophy of government
well and and Market couldn't be any
different their their issues uh invol
their philosophy on taxes on immigration
on energy based Law and Order I mean
they really you can't have two more
different governing philosophies in my
view what would you like to
hear well and yet they both got
reelected in their states look I think
Sean you have an incredible opportunity
to bring America back to real
substantive debates I think America the
I go back whenever I feel blue about
politics I go watch the Kennedy Nixon
debates and they were incredible debates
about real policies I think you have an
opportunity whether it's on tax whether
it's on funding whe whether it's how you
run and what you do with big cities you
have an incredible opportunity to
educate America I think this is going to
be great TV well in spite and I wrote
Gavin in a text in spite of him his team
claiming over and over again it's going
to be two onone maybe even three on one
I'm like three there's only going to be
three of us in the room um uh the
reality is I'm not debating I'll be
asking the questions they get a chance
to exchange the ideas so uh hopefully uh
everybody will be watching and it'll be
worthwhile I think there's an
opportunity for everybody here hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else